in this video we'll be talking about
losal storage disorder this is a very
important topic for usml step one if you
stay tune till the end of this video you
would get a comprehensive overview about
several types of liposomal storage
disorders so as the name suggests
lysosomal storage disorder deals with
some dysfunction in the lome most of
these losal storage disorders are rare
inherited metabolic disorders and this
is due to accumulation of substances in
the cells and the tissue so obviously
lomes are dysfunctional lomes are
considered as recycled beIN of the cells
so obviously when lomes are
dysfunctional things are not recycled
properly so wte clearance is hampered
that is why toxic substances like
polysaccharides lipids Etc basically
accumulates inside the cell or tissue
and that leads to problems so toxicity
builds up with these accumul ated
products and that's the key Essence for
losal storage disorder each of these
losal storage disorder is associated
with some kind of genetic mutation which
lead to abrogation in terms of
production of a protein or an enzyme
these enzymes regulate an important step
in the metabolic pathway so in absence
of those enzymes the metabolic pathways
are gone and that lead to losal
dysfunction so now let's talk about
different types of losal storage
disorder which are really important in
context of USM so first is gous disease
in this case uh the glucos cerebral side
is not cleared properly due to a
deficiency of the enzyme glucos
cerebrosides in TX disease the gm2
gangliosides are not cleared properly
due to a deficiency of the enzyme hexa
suin
days then third is Neiman pics disease
in this case sphingomyelin builds up
because spomin as enzyme is
nonfunctional there is also farby
disease in this case the deficiency
happens at Alpha galactosidase a enzyme
which leads to the accumulation of
glycos fingo
lipids and the last one but not the
least is
mucopolysaccharidosis in this case
mucopolysaccharides builds up due to a
deficiency in the specific enzyme uh
enzyme in that breakdown pathway so
first we'll talk about the gussous
disease and in this case glucose
cerebroside accumulates it's a Lal
storage disorder obviously glucos croas
enzyme is non-functional as a result the
glucos cerebrosides uh accumulates so
glucose cerebrosides enzyme is encoded
by the GBA Gene and in this case the GBA
Gene is mutated which is creating a
faulty glucose cdase enzyme
in normal circumstances glucose
cerebroside break down glucose
cerebroside into glucose and ceramide so
obviously when this enzyme is
non-functional this breakdown doesn't
happen and glucose cerebroside
accumulates inside the cell and that
lead to several problems when it comes
to the inheritance of GBA gene mutation
then it its pattern is autosomal
recessive that means 25% is the chance
that a child would be affected in the
Next Generation so both the ales in this
case has to be m ated in order for the
child to develop this particular
disease now let's talk about the gous
disease uh the subtypes so basically
there are three subtypes the type one
involves spleen bone liver Etc but it
doesn't involve that much of the
neurological symptoms enlarge spleen and
liver is the key symptom of type one
gous disease type one deals with more
the nervous system and it involves
seizure developmental delays and
neurological issues type three is less
severe I mean the severity is between uh
type 1 and type two and it involves both
visceral and neurological symptoms but
the neurological symptoms are not as
severe as the type
two so let's talk about the pathology of
the grous disease in order to understand
the biology we have to understand the
cellular breakdown of lipids so let's
say this is a cell which dies eventually
it has the glucose cerebrosides in their
membrane so basically when this cell is
uptaken by the macras the the lomes
inside the macras would try to break
those glucos cerebroside into ceramide
and glucose right so
obviously this breakdown happens with
the help of glucocerebrosides enzymes
which are present supposed to be present
in the lome now in this particular
disease this enzyme is nonfunctional so
obviously the glucoside would build up
in the lome and that caused the problem
these macras are now non-functional they
have a typical crumpled tissue paper
like morphology and also they are
functionally altered these are actually
termed as Gosher cell this is one of the
pathological Hallmark in the goshes
disease so you can see clearly these
cells are like folded tissue paper so
these cells Gosha cells accumulates in
bone marrow liver spleen and lead to all
the problems spleen and liver actually
enlarge which lead to other problems so
obviously gsha cells are non-functional
they can also secrete several cyto
kindes which can evoke inflammation also
lysosomal enzymes can leak out all these
things can make inflammation even
worse also there could be tissue
scarring now the key symptoms of CER
disease incl includes bone marrow
fibrosis it can be mild to severe there
could be a defect in the RBC production
obviously RBC production would go down
when the bone marrow is affected which
would result in anemia there could be
development of fatigue and tiredness so
obviously there is a reduced blood flow
in the bone due to this case and that is
why there is a high chance that
osteoporosis might develop so obviously
there is a overall bone crisis in type 1
gous disease also type 1 gous disease is
typically characterized by hepat Spen
megali spleen and liver
enlarges so the spleen also uh has roles
in terms of uh breaking down of uh
platelet so obviously there is a
thrombocytopenia in this case and also
since the platelets are abrogated there
could be increased
bruising now there is a acute
neuropathic condition in the type 2
gaues disease because it involves all
the neurological symptom so glucose
cerebroside accumulates in the brain and
several places in the brain which lead
to a problem in the motor skill there is
a decreased muscle tone involved in
muscle spasms or trouble in swallowing
in the babies so the babies often cannot
swallow properly and death might occur
within the few years of the early life
so the symptoms of type 3 gous disease
involve neurological symptoms but the
symptoms appear later on their time uh
on their uh lifespan so obviously there
could be she which occur in the teenage
to the adulthood not very early onset is
there okay so let's talk about the
diagnosis of gsha disease since it's a
genetic disease obviously one can um
test the uh gene mutation by sequencing
methods but also one can look for the
glucose cerebrosides enzyme activity
from the serum sample of the patient
genetic testing is more uh valuable in
terms of proper interpretation but it's
also
costly and also clinical history
classical symptoms these things are
something that clinicians would Al also
look for but there is no cure for this
particular disease there is also enzyme
replacement therapy which can make it
slightly better so glucose cerebros
synthetic glucose cerebras is in infused
through the IV root also there are
substance that can uh there is a
substrate reduction therapy that means
it inhibits enzyme that actually
generates glucose cerebrosides
this is how there could be some
betterment of the
patients and obviously the symptoms has
to be treated the overall problems has
to be managed so basically supportive
management therapy can be uh used as a
treatment strategy now let's talk about
the second one the TX disease TX disease
is a rare inherited genetic disorder
again just like the gous disease it was
termed after Warren T and Bernard Shacks
both were Physicians who described this
disease in this case the problem is in
chromosome 15 there is a gene which
encodes hexam mines a this is an enzyme
which eventually break down gm2
gangliosides so obviously when this
enzyme is defective due to the mutation
then there is a problem in the gm2
ganglioside breakdown so obviously gm2
ganglioside accumulates in the uh cells
and that lead to several problems so
that is the key essence of TX disease so
obviously gm2 gangliosides accumulate
within the lomes of the neuron neuron
which lead to several type of
neurological symptoms this can also lead
to um neuronal damage and neuro
degeneration also overall brain
inflammation is pretty common in case of
TX disease basically gm2 gangliosides
accumulate in the lome and they evoke
inflammation at least hex a null
mutation give much idea about these kind
of neurological symptoms there could be
problems in CNS there could be also
problems in pns both CNS and pns
dysfunction is common in case of these
TX disease there would be obviously
problem with motor skills symptoms of
TAC disease usually appear within the
first few month of the life and it
includes loss of motor skill infants
with TX disease lose the ability to roll
over sit or
crawl also there there would be enlarged
or exaggerated startled response in the
babies there could be loss of cognitive
development they fail to reach many
motor and behavioral M Milestones also
there could be early onset of seizures
in the babies there could be also muscle
weakness and hypotonia seen in the
inheritance pattern of hexa gene
mutation is autosomal recessive in
nature that means 25% is the chance of a
second generation getting this
particular disease this particular uh
hexa mutation is very common in inbred
population like askanazi Jewish
population French Canadian and Amish
population so let's talk about the onent
onset timeline of TX disease so there
could be infantile onset the onset
occurs at 3 to 6 months of the
development there could be juvenile
within 2 to 5 years of the development
chronic in the first or second decade of
the life and then there could be let
onset where second or the third decade
of the life is a time of onset early
onset symptoms includes decre muscle
tone abnormal reflexes Shear Etc and
also there could be visual disturbances
and the L onset symptoms include motor
defects bipolar type disorders Etc let's
talk about the diagnosis of the TX
disease there could be hexa activity
reduction in the patient serum obviously
the sequencing based approach is the
best way to diagnose this and there
could be I Examination during an eye
examination the healthcare provider
actually looks for the cherry red spot
on the back of of the eye and this is
the one of the signature um signature
diagnosis for this particular
disease now obviously the NGS or the
Next Generation sequencing has found out
several mutations which are associated
in the human population and these are
some examples of these U mutations that
are found in mostly asan Jewish
population or in the French
population now let's talk about the
treatment of the tesak disease so
obviously the symptoms has to be managed
so obviously when there is a seizure the
seizure has to be managed with proper
medication there could be also
supportive care like physiotherapy
speech therapy Etc and sometimes the
nutritional support has to be provided
to these patients next we are going to
talk about the Neiman piix disorder
which is another Lal storage disorder in
this case there is a problem in spomin
and cholesterol metabolism sphingomyelin
generally gets broken down into ceramide
and phosph phosphor choline and the
enzyme is
fingo also this particular enzyme is
abrogated in this case of in this case
of nean piix disease in other type of
nean piix disease substances or proteins
that are involved in cholesterol
transport gets abrogated and these
proteins are NPC Gene 1 and NPC Gene 2
products so obviously a mutation in
these two genes lead to the problem so
that ultimately lead to a impaired
cholesterol trans transport now
obviously the first type is the nean
piix disease type one which which
happens due to a mutation in the SM
smpd1 Gene this particular Gene give
rise to the sphingo milin enzyme
obviously when there is a mutation
functional enzyme is not produced as a
result Singin is not broken down and
this is basically termed as type A and
type B nanic disease in type c the npc1
and npc2 gene mutations are more
prevalent this lead to a impairment of
the cholesterol transport so let's talk
about the pathology associated with type
one so obviously when
the um accumulation of the lipid happens
in the macrophases that lead to overall
problem uh in the maccrage functionality
in this case the sphingomyelin
accumulates in the lome so obviously
this spomin as enzyme was supposed to
break down sphingomyelin but since this
enzyme is non-functional it cannot break
Downs fingate accumulates overall in NPD
type A there is a complete reduction of
this particular fingo milin activity
whereas in NP type B There is partial
reduction of the the activity of the
spingo Myas enzyme so obviously the
severity U matters based on these two
types anyway overall we can understand
and the take-home message is fomin
catabolism is
abrogated now let's talk about the
pathology of type A and and type B Neath
pig disease so obviously hepat spomal is
one common feature of these kind of
losal storage disorders also there could
be involvement of lung brain and many
other organs in this
case
so one can definitely look at macras
which shows a lipid Laden flattened
appearance so these are known as the
foam cells these foam cells are
non-functional anyway let's talk about
the onset so there could be early conet
of the npda type of disease or pix
disease the severity is life-threaten in
this case the signs and symptom include
hepatosplenomegaly feeding difficulties
joint pains poor muscle tone and defect
in the lung and the intestine also there
could be a cherry red spot on the
macula type B nanic disease the onset
can be anytime in the life but less
severe than npda remember in
npdb the sphingo and enzyme is partially
active not totally abrogated so signs
and symptoms again include
hepatosplenomegaly lung problems and
thrombocytopenia so now Neiman pic B
disease also has other symptoms like
delayed growth bone problems anemia
visceral organ impairments and many
more now let's talk about the type C
nean pigs Disorder so obviously we have
to understand cholesterol transport in
bit more details to understand this so
LDL is uptaken by the LDL receptors in
endosome overall it forms the L endosome
which fuse with the lome and now what
happens is from this particular fome
they go out with the help of these npc1
and npc2 particular protein and they
then get to the membrane of the cell
where they are important component of
the lipid Bayer so obviously when there
is a problem in this npc1 and npc2 Gene
Gene products this transport to the
membrane doesn't happen properly and
they gets stuck in the losal stage and
they accumulate there that leads to the
problem in this case so neurological
symptoms are quite common in type c
nanic disease there could be it taxia
there could be dystonia there could be
disartria that means difficulty in
speech due to poor muscle control issues
there could be also seizures uh which
can occur at any time of their life also
Nan type c disease also has
hepatosplenomegaly which is common in
many types of lome storage disorder
there could be disrupted bile flow so
obviously it can so bil Rubin can
accumulate in the blood eventually it
might lead to the infantile jaundice
platelets can also be trapped inside the
spleen broken down and that might lead
to thrombocytopenia easy bruising is
pretty common onset of type c nean pig
disease can occur very early in the Life
which lead to decreased muscle tone
decrease motor Milestone there could be
childhood onset which leads to
clumsiness learning difficulties
cognition defect and unsteady gate also
there could be onset of seizures in case
of childhood onset there could be also
teenage onset which has several
psychotic symptoms Progressive cognitive
impairment Etc inheritance pattern of in
nean piix disease is again autosomal
recessive in nature that means again
there is 25% chance that the next
generation one child would be affected
when it comes to diagnosis again looking
at the enzyme activity in the blood is
one tactic second one is is sequencing
and then ultimately clinical history
taking and symptomatic analysis is
important there is no cure for this
particular disease but there are certain
medication which can make things a
little bit better physiotherapy speech
therapy these things can make the life
quality little bit better now we are
almost at the end of this part
particular video and we're going to talk
about the farby disease which is another
losal storage disorder in this case what
happens is the enzyme Alpha galact todas
a is defective in this case what happens
is the globo triy camide this particular
lipid gets accumulated and that lead to
plethora of problems in different organs
there could be cardiovascular problems
renal complications and also to some
extent the neurological complications as
well there could be several treatment
options which includes enzyme
replacement therapy or symptomatic
management of pain um and other symptoms
so that pretty much that that's pretty
much it uh I think in this video we
discussed about all these Lal storage
disorder in pretty much details I hope
this is informative if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe you
can support our Channel using super
thanks you can pay via PTM PayPal or UPI
see you in next
[Applause]
video